foreign
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
propane bear first time watching did not
see this in the cinemas specifically so
we can be here with you guys right now
John should they leave a like they
should absolutely crawler away to that
like button am I right also full-length
Reaction watch along so you sync up with
your own copy of shabane bear available
for our super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page thank you to all who have
joined we also have exclusive things we
cover over there with reaction
highlights and watchalongs included
Gotta Give A mention we gonna be a
WonderCon with koi genre Sunday March 26
11 o'clock AM if you are in attendance
if you're planning on going please come
pay our panel a visit and the last thing
I'm gonna say sometimes you see these
notes for YouTube that we put a little
disclaimer on I'm gonna say this
publicly to the audience to YouTube as
much as this movie is advertised as
based on a true story it's pretty much
fake it's fictional is what we're
watching is fake everything is fake all
performed by professional cast and crew
on a closed track it is all not real and
is not meant to encourage use of
substances or anything of the sort
it's not real and audiences know this
let's go
Lord Miller
Jurassic party that's good that blew my
mind when I found that out
relax
is that Matthew Reese
oh
that's a fun fact
oh good to know fascinating
it's my three dollars a year at work
let's try rayleon is in this the last
movie it's about the band
that is the one thing you said I could
handle myself when I've already made my
decision also oh
that's a guy from Game of Thrones it's
tormund giant Spain
I mean he's a nice book hold up
I didn't mean to
why are you so sensitive
so it begins I told you I could get us
here
thank you I love you
I can't wait for them to die terribly
of course the humpbacks in Iceland and
now this we have such good luck in
nature yes
oh boy
oh no the Bears already ingested I I
think we should leave it it's something
wrong with it come on
come on
oh no
I'm not afraid that's all of course not
oh my God yeah oh no what do we do if
it's black fight back
it's brown lay down
expert
he read the opening crawl
this is where you get
um
no turn and fight
oh no
oh
get your camera
awesome the blood yeah millions of
dollars worth of cocaine dropped from
the sky early today on Emily Jones
reports tonight it was found on the body
of a man who fell to his death when his
parachute failed to open
dumbass that's what you get I know who
that is
full name
Andrew C Thornton II you said full name
but you didn't say his full name
shut up
hey Reba you have a dog right had Border
Collie that's a cool dog
he only had 30 kilos on him any idea
where we could find the rest there's an
area called Blood Mountain
it's a good Mastodon album I want you to
take Eddie with you and he quit Joanie's
the reason why he quit he won't even
come to get his goddamn son I am sick
and tired of watching my kids kid
we talked about this remember me picking
up some extra shifts I was okay with it
until I realized why you're on those
extra shifts so you could go into
overtime with Ray the pediatrician
bear kills this little girl
spelled her name wrong
it says Johnny says John
her name is Buddy
that's why you shouldn't drink solar is
that us hey oh you're such a dumbass
you're such a dumbass
it's cool that Lord and Miller reunited
with him after that solo Fiasco
what could have been mine looking after
Rosette
I have to go to Georgia for the Thornton
case
no no no pretty sure to see us guys
idiots
look I'm not ditching for attention I
just want to paint the waterfall I admit
it he wanted to find out and worry about
it
oh
you just don't want to go to dinner with
a pediatrician yes well his daughter
just ditched school so can you please
just put him on every time I call he's
in the bathroom what the hell is wrong
with him he's not really in the bathroom
you know what people do in the bathroom
if I was a parent I would assume my
child was kidnapped foreign
character actress Margo Martindale is
that perfume it's European oh yeah I'm
expecting someone in a minute smells
expensive
it is
oh [__] he's here
I told you it was big
what's that smell it's European
someone's been smoking
oh oh cigarettes kill people and animals
yeah and you should be educating
yourself instead of endangering the
entire ecosystem
small price to pay for stealing man come
on
Henry
Henry try it cocaine kids
a guy from assembly
the guy from dare you know it's usually
more powdery on the streets
when have you seen cocaine on on the
streets wanna do it whoa what
you've done it before you can do it
again this is bad
I mean I can't do cocaine will shoot
exercising that wouldn't be good fine
knife me oh
well chosen words how do I do it
yeah you eat it
how much
tablespoon's worth
no no
oh what the hell
rookie
you'll be all Numb YouTube this is fake
that is a problem that is ground up
vitamin B12 all right
[__] I normally do
oh
how much you think this stuff is work
let's show drugs together yeah
that's beautiful
this is the most endearing kids and
drugs scene
yep
oh no
this is a classic 80s kind of shot when
Johnny died I should have been there I
didn't need you there I don't hang out
with drug dealers anymore it's against
my Constitution Constitution I think
he's happy she's dead he's not happy she
died blamed her for me leaving the
family business we can call it that I
wonder if he did it to her oh oh Johnny
died of cancer I know maybe he gave her
the cancer
we get a lot of runaways bad apples
she's not a runaway she just came to
paint the can someone just please point
me in the direction of Blood Mountain
come on Eddie I'm done playing this game
you you wanted you were the one who
wanted to play this
still have three more questions they
just ignore the fact the truck's pulling
up yep they got business to attend to I
didn't know Rangers carry guns
park rangers are peace officers
which means we can shoot people
gang of pubes are dangerous gang of pews
teens delinquents
oh
you're messing with the wrong guy he's a
very Birds empty your pockets
no
just there no man good night
break a sink on one of them
okay
no blood stains were good
oh
no a lot more random plots in here than
I was expecting yeah
everybody got one wake up where'd you
find this up on the mountain where's the
rest of it
I don't know I just took out the three
of you in 15 seconds it's about like 30.
yeah plus the editing time compression
gazebo
it's civilian type structure I know what
the [__] a gazebo is I didn't
learn something every day show us where
oh God
go get the [__]
is dragging their bodies how did he not
find the stash
that's an excellent question before they
hide that brick
I was wondering how rosette is doing
realize I hadn't said a proper goodbye I
don't know if dogs think about that sort
of thing but this guy's so sweet
he's got such a naturally a wholesome
quality yeah
Henry hey whoa
Henry what are you doing oh
smart we skipped school no [__] Henry ah
but there was there was a hair a really
terrible bear a bear yeah I know it was
it
don't listen to me
I love this kid I do too so natural
Deedee
a little Bandy
whoa what
hello the monster music
oh my
God and let me go is it gone
is it did the bear go back for more
down
oh yeah oh yeah I got more Yep
nose first
no no
oh
hi
no you're gonna track them all the way
up there
can bears climb trees no am I wrong
about that they're always depicted as
doing such there's something wrong with
it yeah I told you there was oh why is
it acting like this
did you feed a cocaine
Bears can't climb trees of course they
can
then why are you up here why are you up
here this would be a terrifying
situation oh yeah oh yeah
oh no what a shot tasty kid berries up
that tree
okay Russell let it get Henry let it get
Henry it's not your child yeah
get to The High Ground Henry
yikes
what
oh boy
oh my God oh my God
oh
let's go
nice
go to town bear that was that was almost
musical the way that happened a little
man was an extra blonde bears but didn't
know the bear was the cocaine bear
s look it is hilarious
did you hear him scream he's so dead I'd
love to not remember that
but it kind of seems like the thing that
stays with a man forever
he or wise beyond your years boy
to that way she's living in a cave now
I already did
keep him awake yeah I've been
oh dude come on these little [__]
Junkies
Hook em I'm not dumb I don't know they
say I can't keep my Park safe that I'm
unfit for the big leagues I'd have been
hit Yellowstone by now if it weren't for
you [__]
out of my ass
now open it when I say so
I think the Bears just now
oh it is there that's a [__] fire
whoa
what the [__]
covered in brain bear wow
idiots
that was a lot of great timing in this
movie this must have been a hoot to make
there's a bit of like a Phil Lord Chris
Miller meets Cohen Brothers five sure
yeah like the the idiot comedy of Cohen
Brothers yeah
whoa
no I want him to live
I actually like that shot trains you for
your eye to go right to it if you could
see how someone could miss it
oh
it's her blood I could tell
smells like her paint is just red paint
it's not like blood how can you be sure
I'm a nurse Henry how did you get it to
look just like a blood stain
have you ever done cocaine what
that's a yes if it has long-term side
effects for the bear of course well it
could create a habit for the bear what
if they never want to do it again oh
then it should be fine
Papa Bear would be very angry because
drugs are very very bad what if they
would never find out oh Henry
we always find out yeah watch your ass
Henry
keep your nose clean boy
fan of the channel Scott cease
nice angry Ikea guy let's open it oh
yeah I'm doing it all right
oh my God
you don't think golden a concussion
boy
this guy's been shot
obviously
oh
it's a ranger
take her arm off oh no where the frame
was no I thought the same
oh oh no he's looking over there
spooky
Spinners gotta tire out at some point
no ah
you'll crush him
nobody else surprised by that rain this
morning I know I was leave him
oh no do not leave him
you did it you fought back
oh he thinks there's more is that okay
oh God
whoa that's gotta make you feel like a
badass
shut up
oh my God
floor it no
no
foreign
ah
that was the best thing that could
happen yeah you got the easy way out
that was a well done CGI shot damn yeah
flew through the car windshield no it's
real Punchy I'll cross the board and
then that's how I met Rocky and Joe
team man we're planning on moving to New
York City together oh
was
it was so surreal
oh
how did he get there before the this guy
better get to reunite with his dog
you know what's good about that
ambulance scene especially is because
she already accidentally shot someone
that it made it so much more tense
because you thought like he might get
shot yeah 100 yeah the question is is
she still alive out there face down on
that stretcher
I went to the wrong gazebo
stands to reason I promise I don't know
where it went it's just gone where's the
Put the gun down and move away from the
teenager
okay how did he get to the Gazebo before
yeah no they're with you
all the way up there without any noise
how did you get up there well I jumped
from
from me over there but
I hurt my hip a little I can try to
catch you if you want no no you stay
right where you are
oh boy
I told you not to move how do you take
those two fingers off
they're not even next to each other I
know it's like bowling
oh can you grab those for me can I grab
his fingers okay get him
my fingers I need to put them back on
throw them one at a time
it's Majestic shots
hot in a cave bear would never go there
bears never live in caves you're all
gonna get arrested
people I've never been able to [__] in
front of people oh
the Bears come to collect
you are in the best position right now
dude you can get up there hey if this
guy got out there
oh
no oh what a nightmare now's the chance
to shoot the baron
oh no
look
hello he lived
are you are you hurt were you attacked
devil up here oh I'm looking for my
daughter she was attacked by the devil
bear have you seen her you was she alive
you eat at a time like this boy can we
call it truce so I can see if the bear
is dead yeah progress
oh no don't woke it up
oh [__]
Bears addicted you need help bear
no no no don't eat that don't eat that
oh
get away get away for it
no boy it's playing with you I'd stay
still if I were you but just tap out
buddy Eddie please don't die like this
Eddie please
huh
it's like clapping the chalkboard
erasers together there you go girl
there you go
cocaine Christmas
oh no all that fresh snow you're just
making it more powerful
this isn't even the Bear's final form
that bag's worth 14 million we had a
true Center truce's own God where I'm
from we're taking that back to see it
Eddie
oh
who shot him I didn't
uh damn it you want something done right
do it yourself
oh that Bear's gonna Devour the whole
thing now all 14 million of it the Bear
right most of it what the bear
it [__] did cocaine
a lot of cocaine was lost
under my eye oh no they're gonna come
after me
my family if I don't get them every
Penny's worth the cost of being a
superhero man I've been following you
for years they all have
thank you
oh it kind of Shifty
look oh no it's all the take tell me
which way The Bear Went apex predator
high on cocaine you're going towards it
dear North Man
tragedy somebody help him down from up
there
oh stashing it hibernate
wake up in the spring and do the rest
don't move
oh no
that's
what I'm talking about getting the kids
hooked cocaine Bears
cocaine Cubs
um what was that
okay Bears back
go that way go ahead
we're about to walk into the whole
mythology of the cocaine game the lower
centuries of cocaine Bears first Bears
who have discovered cocaine all those
Millennia go
they live here now
let's cut our losses
all right let's just deal with the
Fallout
weird to use some flashbacks yeah
God damn bear
there's there's a lot more out there
we've got to keep looking understand all
night I'm leaving said
geez
save the trader moment who are you I'm a
mom there's kids here let's just go now
I'm not leaving without that cocaine so
somebody better bring it down or
somebody else is gonna die just randomly
Thrice Jesus
get back
oh
no no
Howard David
here catch
why don't you just shot that becomes
yourself too yeah dude
stop God
it's a good thing you don't like you
because you're a piece of crap person
and a bad dad
now you've done it
oh my God they would have died yeah I'd
be freezing yep
oh [__]
oh yeah
no come on cocaine bear oh get up bear
get up cocaine
no he's gonna drop something in front of
that bear by accident
oh
yep there it is
oh yeah
yes
drink it in
about to pull it out
get out of here
oh my god
oh like a pinata
oh
the Hill Gross oh gross
family meal
you just lost the whole meal yeah
foreign
they got something better
oh
this is Johnny
right yeah oh
sinister
we all learned something that day Bears
Like Cocaine people too too her name's
rosette she doesn't like fudge
you should get going
take care of yourself
what are you gonna do just go back to
the force stay away from that come on I
want to look I also don't want to look
don't look let's just cruise on by
oh here come the popo
jeez oh they're gonna shoot them down
wow waiting to be discovered
Rodney are you getting this I swear to
God Carol well the zoom in
wait why are they looking at us like
that oh oh [__] give it a 72 percent yes
yeah no no no keep at it let's see if it
goes up while we're talking about it
John this is a good rating scale that
you're on yeah yeah 72. sure I don't
know I've a solid metric that's just
where my heart's currently at maybe
it'll go up by the end of talking about
it sure
um but no overall it's I mean it
the the main job it sets out to do it
does uh undoubtedly like it was fun
effects are more impressive than one
would expect
for sure right right Sean wouldn't you
agree I would absolutely agree into the
conversation here would you agree that's
Segway there and it's it's more
impressive than you might imagine yeah
if it's better like it looks better and
not just in terms of the visual effects
but also the just the way it's shot
overall I was like this
I was expecting a much uh something that
just leaned significantly more into like
a b movie schlocky territory some
scuzzier
yeah I don't know if scuzzy is the right
word or like more silly I'm pretty sure
I saw the trailer for this
um just the one time I
I think I saw the trailer yeah I've seen
some ad might have not been like a
YouTube pre-roll on TV or something like
that same
um so I I thought it was just was it's
much more sleek and a little bit bigger
than I expected it to go
and so yeah when you when you show up
for the one for the actual parts of the
bear slaughtering and murdering being
the the jaw shark in the woods yeah
that's when I thought the movie was
doing the best that's when I thought the
movie was at its best when it's actually
doing the thing you showed up to go see
yes it greatly succeeds so for that I'm
like oh yeah recommend for that yeah
alone because it gets progressively more
violent
and the the gore delivers
someone was like it's non-stop or I'm
like no I could name like four sequences
yeah that's the non-stop Gore it's just
when Gore happens it's very striking and
they bothered to put in little nuances
that sell it and make it feel achy and
gross and kind of mean you know yeah
it's it's goofy it's like silly Gore
sure it's I was laughing over the time I
was laughing when it was happening it's
it's so over the top that you kind of
laugh at it
uh especially like the whole ambulance
sequence yes
and there were times where I was
impressed with what what impressed me
especially with the direction from
Elizabeth Banks
what impressed me with a lot of the bear
sequences
is how
she did manage to find tension
like genuine tension and suspense I was
never like
oh my God but I bro it's like oh this is
more suspenseful than I was expecting
because I thought it would just be funny
yeah but I'm actually caught up with the
fun tension yeah there was fun tension
to be had and and most of the bear
sequences
um especially before the Gazebo scene I
would say uh anything with with the
ambulance with the kid the little kid
was brilliant I looked Henry especially
was so great she like that kid was great
yeah I cannot wait for him to become the
new Finn wolfhard to see him everywhere
finally get sick of him yeah I don't
know I might have seen that kid in
something else before but I I really
thought he was wonderful he had a great
grasp of the comedy yeah he's just so
natural yeah and who what is that I've
seen that actress in like
billion things Carrie Russell the mom no
no no no the cop the the rain park
ranger you know her name oh a character
actress Marco Martindale yes yes yes uh
she she's in a whole bunch of stuff and
she's always phenomenal I think the last
thing I even saw her in was uh the
Netflix show Watcher yeah yeah she's
she's always great she never misses and
she always understands the assignment
like you see her in dramatic ass movies
and she's you know certainly got the
chops for that but I love seeing her in
a place like this where yeah she's just
as committed and just as Vivid of a
character she's got a great grasp on the
tone Nick I've seen her in dramas I've
seen her in Horrors and comedies and
she's she's a very under recognized
performer
and you think that she'd be the kind of
performer you'd lock into a one specific
kind of role but no no no she can do a
lot and I thought she was excellent here
like I I was I was bummed in the
beginning when she first started getting
attacked yeah
we're killing her off already yeah I was
genuinely bummed about that yeah so what
you got to live longer and have it even
more impactful death uh that that was
that was rich yeah and but like I said I
know I made the comment during the
reaction
um
the fact that I was impressed with the
comedic beat moment of when she
accidentally shoots that one guy and
then when you have the ambulance scene
with the running away there is this
level of several bits of tension because
you're like she might just shoot the
other guy because we're just sorry shoot
the one guy yeah yeah that's such a
chaotic moment yes the ambulance is
bouncing around yeah and there was there
was some really impressive visual
effects that you would like the shot
when the EMT did go through the car
window I was like oh damn they blend
that shitlessly together yeah yeah I
mean this is it's it's impressive I
guess in in relativity it's like I
wouldn't have expected not to even
slight Elizabeth Banks it's just like
you know this is kind of not when did
you discover she directed this I learned
from Conan O'Brien's podcast okay
because as counter number Brian had the
same reaction there's there's this
really funny story where Conan O'Brien
was talking with her and he's like have
you seen this trailer for the movie
cocaine bears like this just looks
insane like he was raving about this
trailer and he had no idea she directed
it yeah it blew it blew my mind because
I didn't find I was aware of the movie
for so long and unlike you I saw maybe
one ad and they did not advertise her
involvement at all and then like the day
the movie came out in theaters I saw
something that referred to her as
cocaine bear filmmaker Elizabeth Banks
and I was like when was somebody gonna
tell me that and I thought that yeah
it's like watching a trailer watching a
movie like this you wouldn't expect that
necessarily but I thought she did a
really nice job of oh how familiar are
you with Elizabeth Banks's career like
it doesn't only only the acting stuff I
have not seen the Pitch Perfect that she
directed or her Charlie's Angels
well knowing her sensibilities and her
her especially especially her sense of
humor yeah she's got like a really edgy
sense of humor
I mean like my introduction to her was
like 40 year old virgin words so I mean
you've seen that right yeah yeah yeah I
think that's a real raunchyroll that
role yeah yeah that's true so there's
something about uh her specific taste
and and then like she's done some a
bunch of like a bunches
yeah I mean she's in a bunch of comedies
but she's also known a bunch of R-rated
stuff but they yeah I mean but that's
got a certain wildness and a certain
raunch about it too but but you know
just like looking at this kind of movie
I wouldn't miss like Charlie's Angels
I'm like okay I could see that whereas
this I never would have guessed and I
thought she did a really nice job of
pulling this kind of like there are
multiple ways you can go with a movie
like this and I thought that they did
well and I know it's not for everybody
uh but to yeah kind of play it
straight-ish even though you can tell
from behind the camera that there is a
lot of fun happening but everything yeah
like that shot with the ambulance like
that takes a lot of planning prep and
yeah there are a lot of other technical
people working on things like that but I
think that's indicative of the style
throughout the movie because there are a
lot of really fun and interesting fluid
shots and like that one bit with the
bloody handprint in the window like more
restrained shots that are still pretty
clever like this had a a really
confident style about it that also knew
how to sell the effects really well and
how to accentuate the gore gags and how
to you know ring the fun out of it with
ever without ever sacrificing that sense
of like visceral nastiness at the core
of just what the situation itself is so
it's like I said she she managed to
strike a really nice balance between
like light-hearted that kind of like you
know pulpy you're in your chair your
chair like this would be really fun with
a rowdy crowd but at the same time it's
not so down that hole that it's just a
joke or at least that it's like only
carrying itself like a joke
fair if that makes sense yeah no that
does make sense now I get where you're
coming from on that
I I did like the uh the cop too the lead
Detective I thought it was excellent
yeah well that's the thing is like the
uh like the Journey of cocaine bear for
me has been like steadily discovering
that more and more and more and more
people are involved with this and so
this really is like an ensemble movie
and like it's like what I like about a
movie like Jason lives is that all the
characters are given a story beat of
flavor some some kind of day that's
happening as they all converge upon
killer force and I thought they did
nicely to do that here but also have
just like a broad Ensemble so every plot
line pretty much has like someone of
note who you know is gonna bring their a
game and has a likely chance of
understanding the assignment yeah
definitely and I think that cop do you
know who that cop is I know I've seen
the actor I don't know yeah I don't know
his name either but you've definitely
seen him and stuff yeah he does have
this I think he's played like cops
before yeah he does have a very
wholesome quality about him uh where you
are very much in dear to him right off
the bat and then when he has time to be
like a detective you believe him I think
he does an excellent job like that
standoff on top of the Gazebo when you
really get to see him be a cop it's
really on display where he can play a
bit more of the softer sides with his
dog and everything and then have that
whole thing on top of a gazebo
uh and
um Alden ehrenreich
uh who's um I I I've seen solo I thought
he was great and hail Caesar which is
probably more Akin too this is like a
roll somewhere between that I guess
because he's not like fully dumb in this
movie you know in fact he starts off
like he's really stupid and then it
evolves into you seem like the smartest
one in the group yeah
who just has like the spiritual
knowledge that this is not the life you
should be living yeah yeah because they
do start to set him up like he's gonna
be the idiot and then he doesn't he
doesn't remain that to character uh but
I I really like what he brought to here
I thought he was having a lot of fun
with this role and I do I do hope more
people notice all the narrow because
because even have you seen hail Caesar
I've not seen hail Caesar uh he's a
scene stealer to me yeah he's a total
dumbass and I felt but he's a seed
stealer in that movie to me I mean I'll
never forget like I I think the movie I
saw it in the theaters with some friends
as one of those why a romance
adaptations called uh it's either
Heavenly Creatures or Beautiful
Creatures or something like that and
he's the lead and even in that movie
which I'm sure is not well liked or
loved you know over time I was like this
guy's got something though I really like
watching him yeah and uh it's it's like
this seems like a cool vehicle because
the solo stuff has I I imagine cast a
certain Paul over his career for you
know unfair reasons and so then to see
him pop up in something like this and
again like fully understand the
assignment and bring so much personality
but without it being you know
distracting or anything like that like I
don't know I thought he did a great job
and I really liked his chemistry with uh
O'Shea Jackson and the way that they
yeah the movie starts out and you feel
like oh this is going to be like a bunch
of people's idiocy and incompetence sort
of creating the Snowball Effect that
will all Collide but after a while it
kind of wasn't that like there was you
know little misnomer little errors and
things at the beginning and there were
dumb decisions made but once everybody
kind of gets to the park
you know that gives way
and it's not as much about you know the
the bumbling stupidity it's more just
like oh yeah these characters all have a
certain splash of color
yeah yeah I mean I think regardless of
why I would put it at 72. instead of a
full 100. I think regardless uh there
was always an effort to be more than on
display there was always
there was always a conscious effort to
add some color and personality to all
the characters and I really really am
appreciative of that like that I would
never fault a single moment of this
movie whether it be in writing or
directing or acting as as lazy I think
where the movie would
tiptoe between like this is not there's
something about the
just there's something about the Rhythm
in the scenes of just human interaction
and cutting back and forth where it just
wasn't really
it would fluctuate between enjoyable to
feeling like it's the Rhythm and
Energy's weighing this movie down
where sometimes the
a scene would genuinely feel dramatic
but it wouldn't feel like the dramas
I'm not feeling the weight of the drama
and the comedies
a real hit or miss when it comes to like
the dialogue that it wasn't as it didn't
it weirdly lacked a lot of like Phil
Lord and Chris Miller Pizzazz and energy
and and comedic Rhythm that at times
when they would come because they have
like very different tones that they're
cutting between yeah with the Keri
Russell storyline is very tonally
different than the story with O'Shea
Jackson and Alden Aaron Reich and like
like I said everyone is committed
everyone's doing a good job it's just
sometimes the human story lines were
it would just kind of be not it would it
would fluctuate between I'm enjoying
this too this is not that interesting if
I'm just gonna speak like matter of
factly that I wasn't always as engaged
by it to the point where I'm like this
movie was only 95 minutes or something
but I still felt overstays welcome by
like 10 to 15 minutes I was like it's
gonna be like 10 to 15 minutes short uh
even for you know may rest in peace the
wonderful fantastic actor Ray Liotta but
I don't think Ray Leona knew exactly the
kind of movie he was in I think he was
playing it way too he played it like
very serious uh to the point where I
didn't feel like it actually
complemented the movie I thought it I
thought it was
um it's the kind of role I don't know if
it was like I'm gonna play the dry
straight you know villain or something
like that I don't know if that was like
the intention
there was something about though that
the portrayal there that I did feel
weighed the energy of the movie down
like that weirdly this movie I never
really felt like found a an energetic
romp ramp up you know it was kind of it
would kind of be like
this is really entertaining when bear
stuff is going on yeah and then it just
so when that's there huh and then it's
just
like
I want to say a flat line but it it
didn't escalate an energy to me in terms
of enjoyment yeah it's like the the
experience of watching the extended
periods of just character beats don't
match the same highs or energy as the
bear stuff and not that that has to be
obviously but yeah they do kind of feel
like they could be slightly different
movies I think because they instead of
embr what what I think happened is this
is just theoretical like purely
theoretical is that I think because they
had the whole based on a true story
thing that they tried making some of
this feel like based on a true story
like it could it may be possible somehow
like they could have gone more they they
only gets ridiculous when there's like
violence right and I felt like the
Ridiculousness could have
escalated more with just the human story
lines and then that way you get like a
real energy and rhythm going that keeps
ramping up and is constantly like fun
yeah and so it never really quite gets
there to that height from for myself
personally nor does it when it gots to
be serious quite get there for me either
you know yeah it's an interesting duck
and I think Ray Liotta partly to me
functions I I do agree it's like I feel
like he could be bigger he could he
could be you know committing to the role
but not taking himself so seriously and
I think that's maybe part of the reason
you cast a person who brings that level
of Association is like you want some of
that Ray Liotta heavy but for what this
is you probably want it to be a little
more coked out in terms of the zaniness
um but I do think this is interesting
because this is yeah in a lane of movies
that is clearly trying to bring some
kind of exploitation experience and
something that is certainly hearkening
back to a certain kind of Cinema from a
certain era and we're you know steeped
in the 80s uh and there is that sort of
grind Housey albeit very polished
quality and I think that there are
multiple ways to go about that and some
people choose to go like full-on balls
to the walls like nothing is serious
this is all a big crazy Meme and then
you can go the sort of this direction I
feel like which is this almost feels
like a movie
that came out of the actual time that it
is homaging in that you watch some of
those movies and they will feel like oh
yeah like this High concept this should
be like crazy throughout but like the
character stuff just kind of like you
know happens and unfolds and you know
you're just there with that and then
there are these crazy moments that jut
in and I feel like in like like that's
why I thought just to quickly interject
that's why I thought the little boy was
perfect yeah because a little boy kind
of compliments the like to have like a
straight character like Carrie Russell
and then the little boy
that those two juxtapositions work so
well in the storyline yeah you introduce
what are they Swedish in the beginning
yeah yeah he's like like cartoonishly
Swedish characters in the beginning and
then they're cutting to this like story
with
like a drama heavy story or something
like that but yeah the energy of that
that I don't feel like I actually get
what you're saying because I thought
that too about how this kind of plays
like that something from the 80s like
like it is one of those movies plugged
out and like ah yeah it could have been
could have been a little better but I
think some of those that part of the
storyline didn't lean enough into its
self-awareness yeah it's like I think
that what could have made this I think
transcend a little harder and maybe be
more agreeable for everyone is yeah a
little bit more of a unifying
I don't know what it would be chaos or
zaniness or something like I think I I
like when a movie like this commits to
taking itself not seriously but playing
itself straight at least yeah like I
don't want them to go so far as to you
know
completely destroy all the tension by
being just like nothing's real but yeah
I feel like they maybe could have split
the difference a little better to
embrace the meme just a little harder
because yeah like I can understand what
people mean when I've heard that
complaint of like yeah like it's mostly
just people there's like a detective guy
and he likes his dog and you're just
like hanging out a bunch of random
people and then the bear comes in and
that stuff's cool like I guess that
wasn't my experience but I could see
easily how that could be someone's
experience and I think that yeah with a
little bit more I don't know overt
quirkiness in the Dynamics of the human
stories it could have made them like
I'll go back to Jason lives like there's
a a bigger slight element of humor in
those moments where it's like we're
cutting to some random characters and
they're having a day and and it's kind
of funny and quirky and here I felt like
okay maybe Don't Stray so far into like
let the actors act like let's let's
bring a little bit more bombast here
um and then that could make this you
know like the full on experience that I
think the the title and the concept
implies and yeah you are
uh you know it's pretty well trodden
territory now for people to go well the
real bear just ate it and pretty much
died immediately so like we know that
this isn't that true of a story is that
the is that the whole story is that all
that really happened I'm probably
oversimplifying but that's that's
essentially the gist I've I've often
gotten is like it's not this exactly
it's just like the bear found a bunch
took it and then probably went crazy and
died yeah and and so yeah it's like
we're turning this into something that
is a roller coaster and that is clearly
departing from reality yeah I think it
was a little bit at odds with itself in
some of the scenes without the bear that
sometimes it felt like okay are we
trying to play this series or we're
trying to play this like uh like a drama
or we're trying to play this with some
horror undertale what are we playing
with exactly I think you had a really
great call ins in likening it to a Coen
brothers comedy because I think the only
missing ingredient is you need the
cocaine bear urgency to apply to all of
the character scenes yeah whereas
sometimes that part of the movie doesn't
seem like it quite applies so you still
have something that's quirky and amusing
and fun that you might be engrossed in I
often was but at the same time I think
there's just an element of coked outness
yeah I think I think the urgency word is
probably the best call yeah because it
does seem to to lack that like
especially when you're cutting between
the different plots is you have Kerry
Russell looking for the daughter
which is like okay there's a clock there
you gotta save her yeah but then you
have this one thing with the other guys
who are just like Meandering through the
woods to get them back yeah yeah
and uh yeah it was kind of zigzag like
it seemed like they created a lot that I
got to the point where I was sort of
questioning of
were they just trying to fill in the run
time here to make it a solid 90 minutes
I guess yeah because yeah that was that
was it was it would it would jump back
and forth it lacked a certain type of
punchiness with the with the humor and I
think the sense of urgency would would
Aid that you know because I like
comedies like like I think comedies that
like Horrible Bosses for example uh do a
great job at doing with having that
sense of urgency throughout
um where they they do the things that
I'm talking about
um game night I think is a great example
uh of having that too where it yeah so
other than that you know uh that's why I
would rate it where I'm personally at uh
I still but I but again I would I have
to leave it at I I could greatly commend
regardless the the effort to try to do
more than what you normally would do
with these kind of movies where they
really tried giving life to like
everyone showed up on screen yeah and I
think like I I appreciate I would rather
have that than not because oh yeah
definitely yeah because it is a joy to
have like that attention paid to having
characters having stories going on
having the actors then you know their
presence is Justified just beyond you
have connections and these people or
game and so yeah like I do appreciate
this movie for being like in many ways a
lot better than it probably deserved to
ever be uh and in that it's weird it's
like in that way I'm quite impressed I'm
like this was a blast this was really
fun and I can see how this would be like
completely Bonkers with the right kind
of crowd however you know when you come
back with your kind of sober glasses on
you're like yeah you know like this is
again this is one of those this reminds
me of a movie where I would hear about
it from the 80s and people being like oh
man I love it it's so Bonkers and then
watching it and being like yeah I like
this a lot this is pretty crazy it's not
quite as crazy as I was led to believe
but you know yeah it's still got what
you want it's just how much of that
proportion are you as a viewer gonna
feel yeah because I was thinking to
myself that I'm having fun but there are
times where I'm really not having that
much fun like the fun would sometimes
let its foot off the gas pedal for me
yeah it would dip in for me it rarely it
didn't really ever dip below Pleasant I
was always happy to be watching it but
there yeah I wasn't bored yeah yeah uh
but yeah I would definitely fluctuate
between like yeah this is fun not as fun
as I thought but it's fun yeah they
never had like but I thought all the I
thought all the bear scenes were great
yeah the thing you show up for that that
is great and and it's good I think that
they did measure the bear appearances
because you know that's also kind of
very calculated yeah which I think you
have to because that's a you know that's
a mocap effect of some kind that they're
that they're doing but also yeah I mean
you know you want to build some tension
and you don't just want to show your
killer all the time in the slasher movie
or the monster movie or whatever it is
all right guys well what did you think
about this movie leave your rating down
below uh do you want a sequel what other
animals do you want to see in just the
white powder ooh leave a like subscribe
check us out WonderCon hey let's end
this with a pink
Daniel Gallagher thank you so much for
being here Daniel DG Daniel
come on man we know what you do you keep
saying you're part of the pharmaceutical
industry in Scotland and no one can stay
close to this patreon for that long at
the tier your rad off of pharmaceutical
money that's right no no man we know
you've been pushing the angel dust
around town we know what's going on dude
I'd hustle and you know what man
mad respect you got a hot girl you gotta
take care of you gotta keep that bank
account looking filthy yeah you know
what I mean man you gotta keep her in
Gucci stilettos I understand what it
takes so respect to the game don't hate
the player hit the game and uh I gotta
say man
if you're looking for more clientele
well
give me my address I got some cats who
would love to try some of your products
oh they they could use some they're too
mellow they're way too calm and I feel
like what you are able to supply
oh man I know they'd have a great time a
little zap So Daniel keep pushing what
you got to push to stay part of our
patreon page and know that we support
you back just as equally 100 my friend
undo p